what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched moon
night episode three and a lot of people
are saying that it's their favorite
episode so far in the series and i have
to say i agree with them in this episode
we got a lot of really cool things we
got the gods coming together in a
council using their avatars to
communicate with one another we got a
new personality coming out of mark
steven who is most likely jake lockley
and did you catch that really really big
black panther easter egg and right now
moon knight is no more at the very end
of the episode we see konchu get turned
into stone and now moon knight is no
more mark and steven don't have those
powers so i've broken this episode down
into 35 different very important points
that you need to know so let's dive
right into it and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest marvel
videos so to start this off real quick
let's talk about that ending the gods
told konchu in the council that was held
that if he changes the sky again and
basically does anything that lets the
humans know of the god's existence they
will turn him into stone now
unfortunately in order to find ahmed's
tomb they needed to know what a certain
constellation looked like about two
thousand years prior now konchu being a
god and being around back then two
thousand years ago knew what the sky
looked like and said that he could
actually bring back the night sky and
sadly he knew that doing this was going
to make the other gods turn him into
stone which is what we saw happen but
leila was able to get the coordinates of
ahmet's tomb so it wasn't for nothing
and he did tell stephen to tell mark to
rescue him and free him but of course
the big question that people are asking
now is that since konchu's gone does
mark and steven still have the ability
to turn into moon knight and mr knight
and the answer to this question is no
kanchu makes this very clear early on in
the episode where he says that the gods
if he provokes their wrath will turn him
into stone mark jokes and says well that
wouldn't be the worst thing but then
conscious says well let's see how you
would last against hero without the
healing of the moon knight suit so at
the end there when konchu gets turned
into stone the powers of moon knight go
away which means steven and mark are
definitely in much more danger as they
don't have the ability to heal anymore
so that's the ending explained now let's
jump into the 35 different points that
you should know about this episode and
we'll start at the beginning now the
first point is the entire opening scene
who exactly is maya well here we learned
that she is originally from egypt that
is her home she hasn't been there in 10
years and apparently can't really go
back at least legally because she is
having a fake passport created for her
now the person talking to her according
to the subtitles is a person named
legaro now legaro in marvel comics was a
person called dynaman now this person
was born in the fourth dynasty of the
old kingdom of pharonic egypt so it kind
of has a little bit of a link to what
we're talking about right now however
legarro translates to dynaman man of
power and legaro appears to be a woman
here so i don't think there's much of a
connection probably just a tiny little
easter egg but legaro has known leila
for a long time because she apparently
knew her father now we have no mention
of laila's mother at all so there is a
tiny chance that it could be her mother
but i'm actually assuming that it's
probably just a mother figure to her
especially because when she talks about
her father's death she says that's your
baggage not mine but the main point to
take away from this opening scene is
that layla kind of steals ancient
egyptian artifacts and this is most
likely why she can't legally return to
egypt which is why she has to get a fake
passport because she has to follow mark
point two we find arthur harrow and his
cult following in the middle of the
desert the scarab compass has led them
to amit's tomb but not exactly the
compass simply points down as we find
out later on in the episode arthur can't
find the actual tomb this is why he ends
up at mogart's place looking for the
sarcophagus they have the general
location of the tomb but not the actual
location of the tomb which is why he has
everybody digging for it point three
mark is now in egypt and we see him get
into some pretty bloody fights and
notice that in these scenes mark doesn't
fight with the suit he has this power on
his own he's an excellent fighter but
the suit can heal him so if he ever got
stabbed he could simply summon the suit
afterwards and it would heal him but a
big takeaway here is that mark doesn't
actually have full control over the body
in the past episodes he's mentioned that
the person with the body has full
control but as we see here he doesn't
steven actually manages to take the body
from him several different times mark is
fighting haro's followers trying to
question them to know where he's digging
but right as mark has defeated them
steven takes control over the body and
mark finds himself in a car on the way
to the airport but then mark sees
harrow's followers again he catches up
to them but then steven interferes again
this causes him to get knocked out but
when he awakens he has a knife stabbed
into one of the guys and he notices that
he's killed the other one as well and
the only one left is the kid mark says
steven what did you do and steven says i
didn't do this which brings us to point
four there's another personality inside
of this body that is not mark and is not
stephen this is most likely jake lockley
in the comics there are four personas
mark spector who is the mercenary steven
grant who actually in the comics is a
billionaire and then there is jake
lockley who is a cab driver who gets
information from the streets we've yet
to be introduced to jake lockley but
here it is very apparent that there's
another personality inside of this body
and it's most likely him and apparently
he's savage it looks like he just killed
two of these guys no problem whatsoever
also side note we'll call it note four
and a half this was pointed out by two
of my followers sue and isaac gump they
made mention that jake lockley or this
other mysterious personality is most
likely the person that made the date
with the girl in the first episode
steven didn't do it because he had no
recollection of the date whatsoever and
mark wouldn't have done it because mark
is married so it was most likely jake
that asked this girl out so it looks
like jake is not only ruthless but also
a smooth talker point five the wrath of
the gods and this is the part that i
mentioned in the beginning it's a very
important part because conscious says
the gods will imprison him in stone mark
says the joke about it not being that
bad but then conscious says good luck
fighting hero without the healing powers
of his suit again confirming that at the
end of this episode with konchi and
stone mark can no longer summon the suit
point six mark cannot find out where
harrow is digging to find almonds too so
he asked kanchu if he has any ideas and
kanchu says no he's got a bad idea but
the idea is going to get them in front
of the gods to plead their case so
konchu makes an eclipse happen remember
he's the god of the moon that's his
power he pulls the moon over the sun to
signal to the gods that he needs to talk
and remember he's banned so he just
can't talk to the gods anymore which is
why he has to do such big theatrics that
the whole entire world sees harrow sees
too and he mentions that he says he'll
be summoned soon because he knows
exactly what kancho is doing seven the
black panther easter egg that you need
to know about in this scene of the
meeting of the gods where they meet
inside the great pyramid of giza as mark
walks in steven says oh my gosh i can't
believe we're inside the great pyramid
of giza and you see a bunch of different
statues and in an almost blink and
you'll miss it moment on the right side
you can notice a statue of bast the
black panther god in the comics yes bast
is a part of the iniad and is one of the
eldest gods and is a child of autumn or
amin ra otherwise known as king of the
gods now we've actually seen bast in
black panther in the opening scene kind
of they tell the story that millions of
years ago when the vibranium meteor hit
the earth the five tribes of wakanda
were at war with one another until a
warrior shaman received a vision from
bast the black panther god that led him
to the heart-shaped herb and turned him
into the first black panther and king of
wakanda and in the comics it's pretty
much the same there was a warrior named
bashinga that prayed to the panther god
to give him the strength to defeat some
demons that were caused by the vibranium
and he became the first black panther
and he became the avatar for best so i'm
assuming at some point in time probably
in wakanda forever we are going to see
an avatar for best point eight hathor
the goddess of music and love and her
avatar yatzel it looks like hathor and
konchu at one point in time clearly had
a relationship with each other which is
most likely why she ends up helping out
mark and koncho at the end of the
meeting yatzel says that hathor and
konchu used to be old friends and then
hathor whispers in yatsel's ear in which
attil says she says it was not so long
ago that kanchu enjoyed hathor's
melodies definitely guessing that there
was somewhat of a relationship here
especially if you consider that hathor
is the goddess of love and she ends up
telling them that they need to look for
sinful sarcophagus point nine something
to take note of the gods do not exist on
earth they are not there which is why
they take over their avatar's bodies to
speak in fact conscious says return from
the opulence of the overvoid before you
lose this realm now in the comics the
egyptian inead gods hail from a place
called celestial heliopalis which is a
small pocket dimension that is adjacent
to earth which is where i am assuming
that the overvoid is point 10 we learned
just how cunning and manipulative arthur
harrow is konchu and mark accuse him of
trying to resurrect ahmet and that he's
looking for her tomb but arthur uses
mark's mental disorders against him and
says that konchu is abusive to his
avatars and since kanchu has already
been banned the gods just kind of take
hero's word for this and what's really
interesting here is they don't seem to
want to investigate any of the desert or
see if hero is really looking for amit's
tomb at all but we do learn that even
the gods don't know where ahmed's tomb
is point 11 the gods stay out of earth's
business essentially they don't even
interfere with their avatars anymore
they just have them observe almost like
the watcher but for very different
reasons they say that the gods gave up
on humanity because they say humans gave
up on them they leave conscie with a
warning that if he does anything to make
the humans aware of them again like
causing a random eclipse and changing
the sky they will turn him into stone in
which we go to find out that they were
very true to their word point 12. sinful
sarcophagus holds another way to find
the tomb of amit now in this show sinfu
is spelled s-e-n-f-u
but in actual history there is somebody
with a very similar name spelt
s-n-e-f-e-r-u
which would be kind of like sninfuru and
this person was responsible in his time
as pharaoh for constructing many
different pyramids and his son and
successor was kofu who would be the one
to finish building the great pyramid of
giza where the inead just met so it
would make sense that this person would
actually be sinfu or a play on sinfu
that they're talking about in this
episode and according to yatzel if they
find senfu sarcophagus they will find a
map to ahmet's tomb point 13 mark goes
back to the black market where he ends
up finding layla or i should say leila
finds him and it's very convenient that
she knows exactly where to find him
isn't it this scene is interesting
because she says that her name might
piss off a few locals it makes you
wonder what she did or perhaps what her
father did while he was an archaeologist
there however since she needed a fake
passport to get back into the country
it's most likely that she stole from
many people there and probably stole
something pretty important also note
that mark says it's not the locals he's
worried about he looks up at konchu when
he says this because he's worried about
konshu choosing her as his next avatar
point 14 which is kind of two different
points stephen and layla are now on a
boat to go see somebody named mogart and
here we can see that layla and steven
clearly still love each other but mark
doesn't want her to get hurt and he
doesn't want her to be conscious next
avatar so he left her but more
importantly he clarifies that he's
always had control over stephen until
now and we've seen this many times in
this episode where steven simply takes
control over mark why is it different
now why is he kind of having more mental
episodes now could it simply be the
stress of everything or is something
else underlying making everything happen
plus not to mention another mysterious
identity most likely jay blockley was
revealed in this episode as well so
clearly mark spector's mental stability
is declining point 15 they arrive to
mogart's place and they mention magipore
so major falcon in the winter soldier
connections here as it's mentioned that
layla was in madrapore now we know that
layla steals artifacts and magipore is a
city for criminals with a lot of
artifacts that sell there so she could
have gone there to sell the artifacts
and steal them as well as we hear
moguard eventually tell her that he was
ready to make peace with her implying
that she might have stolen some things
from him before this could also connect
her to sharon carter as we all know that
sharon carter is the power broker who
basically runs magipor it's also worth
noting that this is truly the first mcu
connection that we've heard in moon
night no other mentions of anything else
in the mcu have been brought up yes
we've seen the statue of bast but they
didn't bring that up it's simply there
in the background so this is our first
mcu connection point sixteen and this
one is pretty sad mogart mogart is
actually played by the actor gaspard
uliel who died only months ago sadly so
rest in peace to him and peace to his
family but point 17 is about who he
actually is anton mogart or otherwise
known in the comics as midnight man now
midnight man in the comics has major
moon knight connections midnight man was
a costumed criminal who stole art
treasures until one time he was stopped
by none other than moon knight and then
of course from there he sought revenge
and he worked with bushmen who was the
person who originally killed mark to get
revenge on moon knight and i wouldn't be
surprised if mogart goes on to work with
harrow since they basically replaced
bushmen with hero and note that we don't
actually see mogart die in this episode
mark hits him with a crescent but he
doesn't actually die or at least we
didn't see it and you know how marvel is
if you don't see it there's a chance
they could come back point 18 they get
to the sarcophagus and layla confirms
that it's legit but doesn't see any type
of directions to find amit's tomb this
is where stephen comes in in the
reflection and he says that it's coded
now we see more bickering between mark
and stephen each wanting to stay in
control over the body but they actually
work together here steven knows about
ancient egypt but mark knows how to
fight and steven agrees to help in order
for there not to be a bloodbath so
steven says check the cartonage fold
them and put them together that should
arrange a constellation which should
tell you where the tomb is however
unfortunately they are interrupted which
brings us to 0.19 a point that could
easily be overlooked here the guy pulls
a gun on mark and mark's training comes
out and he easily takes the gun from the
guy okay no big deal he can easily say
sorry it was a reaction but layla kind
of blows it here she says mark
don't in which she reveals his true name
not the fake name that she told mogart
now point 20 unfortunately hero comes
and he kind of makes a mess out of
everything this proves though that the
scarab compass didn't work 100
it took them to the general location of
the tomb but after all the digging he
can't find it yet so harold went after
the same clue as mark and layla to try
and better narrow down his search that
and you know to simply screw up mark and
layla to try and keep them from getting
to the tomb themselves now he does kind
of make a little bit of a mess he
mentions leila's father's murder and
that mark doesn't tell her the truth and
he doesn't tell her because he believes
that she won't love her after now this
is most likely due to the fact that he
was there when her father died her
father was most likely killed by the
person who ended up killing mark in the
comics it was bushman and it very well
could be bushmen in the show when they
do a flashback of what happened he just
might not be a prominent villain in the
show but i'm assuming arthur is trying
to make it seem like mark is the one
that actually killed leyla's father and
that may be what some people believe but
i don't think so i think bushman killed
her father and then mark rebelled
against him much like what happened in
the comics now hero gets mogart's
attention by using some of amit's powers
with his staff but then mark decides to
summon the suit and we get point 22
which is the iconic moon knight crescent
cape he jumps in the air and we see it
in all of its glory and then he goes on
to use it to block some bullets and save
layla layla says borrow him some time he
says he can do that which brings us to
23 we get a good look at moon knight's
powers and abilities here we see that
the suit is bulletproof and we can see
him throw his crescent darts and we see
him use his crescents as well point 24
while mark is fighting layla gathers the
map and we see a look at her fighting
skills showing us that she's been
through a lot as well with mark where
she's clearly picked up how to fight
after all she is the wife of a mercenary
it makes sense that she could throw down
point 25 here we see moon knight kick
some serious butt he breaks some arms he
breaks some legs and he takes bullet
shots like they're nothing but steven is
fighting him the whole entire time until
he eventually manages to take the body
from mark without even using a
reflection and as soon as he takes the
body he turns into mr knight immediately
and stephen thinks his nice guy attitude
can solve everything and that they can
just talk a bit but he finds out really
quickly that these killers don't talk
they kill and he gets impaled by a spear
he then quickly gives the body back to
mark saying take the body back take the
body back and point 26 notice how mark
doesn't really get hurt when he gets
stabbed this is because of course the
suit has the power of the god konchu and
although he doesn't look too hurt they
do manage to pin him down with enough
spears now again konchu mentioned
earlier on that the suit has the ability
to heal him but it looks like he's not
in too much pain as he gets stabbed but
moon knight getting pinned down causes
layla to kick into high gear and pull
out some secret daggers that were part
of her clothing then she shoots somebody
that's on a horse but unfortunately
mogart knocks her down and is about to
go at her again which fortunately causes
mark as moon knight to completely crush
the people who were stabbing him and
holding him down he takes what he was
stabbed with and he stabs them in the
stomach and the chest which is something
we don't see too much in the mcu it's a
little bit more violent and it's kind of
cool to see mark saves layla and hits
mogart with a crescent and notice like i
said before he doesn't actually die at
least we don't see it which means he
could come back point 27 they finally
get in a car and are heading away but
what was harrow actually talking about
layla wants to know but mark plays coy
he says that it's not true what he said
and he's just trying to get inside of
their minds and break them apart but
again mark was a mercenary before so he
was most likely there when her father
was murdered so this is most likely what
hera was talking about point 28 they
finally come to a stop in the desert and
they try to assemble the fabric of stars
to make a constellation but mark can't
figure it out he says there's only
pieces and fragments and this of course
is where stephen comes in in fact layla
says that they need steven and even
konchu says i summon the gods you summon
the worm basically stating that hey i
did my part you gotta do your part and
bring them out and it's funny that
steven knows all of this because all he
does when he's awake trying to stay up
at night is learn about all of this and
he tries to stay awake to keep mark from
coming out which he didn't know at the
time but now he does and it's kind of
ironic that mark caused steven to learn
all of this and mark realizes that
steven has to come out but notice how
pissed he is that he has to bring him
out ripping the mirror off of the car
in point 29 stephen immediately gets
down to it he knows exactly what to do
stating that egyptians invented modern
navigation using the sun and the stars
instead of landmarks since the desert is
just vast nothingness stephen makes it
work but unfortunately it's not that
simple the constellation was marked over
2000 years ago which makes it not
entirely accurate so the only way to
know is to know exactly what the stars
looked like that night 2 000 years ago
fortunately they have the god of the
moon on their side whose moon god powers
apparently include the ability to turn
back the night sky but it comes at a
cost konchu knows he'll be turned to
stone but he still does it he still
turns back the stars showing us that he
truly is out to do good and not bad he
seemed a little sketchy by picking mark
someone with a mental disorder and
threatening him by saying that he'll
pick his wife as the next avatar but
here we see that overall he does want to
save everybody and keep harrow from
resurrecting ahmet point 30 a little bit
of foreshadowing here konshu tells
stephen to tell mark to free him once
he's imprisoned in stone now since we
know that since konchu's gone mark and
steven no longer have the suit we know
that they'll need to get it back
eventually which means they'll need to
free konchu and i'm guessing that this
is going to be a super epic scene in one
of the future episodes in point 31
together steven and konshu turn back the
stars and kanchu is imprisoned in stone
in a stone statue of himself and we
notice that this completely drains
stephen and he no longer has the suit to
restore his health and energy kanji gets
imprisoned because everyone in the world
can see what he's doing reversing the
night sky which goes directly against
what the gods told him to do so they
imprisoned him keeping to their word but
point 32 it works leila manages to get
the coordinates and now they know
exactly where ahmed's tomb is and this
is where we leave stephen and layla for
the episode but point 33 hero visits
giza to visit konchu statue and i'm
beginning to think that some of the gods
might not be so good why are they
letting hero just come and visit why
didn't they investigate the accusations
that mark and konchu were holding
against harrow and notice that the
avatar of osiris says that kanchi was
now tethered to the place like many
before him what exactly are these other
gods doing to get imprisoned and why is
the inead being so harsh on them and why
was konchu banished for not abandoning
humanity when the other gods apparently
did abandon humanity why would they
banish him for wanting to do good it
kind of seems like some of them at least
have their own agenda here and i
wouldn't be surprised if some of them
ended up being bad now point 34 arthur
says that konchu broke him now konshu
tends to pick mentally unstable avatars
so he can more easily control them what
did he do to arthur though is arthur
unstable himself now obviously he is a
little bit he agrees with ahmet he
thinks that she should judge people way
before they even commit crimes including
killing babies for something that they
might do 30 years in the future so
clearly he is a little unstable but i
wouldn't be surprised if there's a
little bit more to this than we think
and we end with point 35 we end with
arthur saying his torment forced him but
perhaps his torment isn't what we think
either maybe it's the fact that konchi
was punishing people after they already
did bad things this is maybe what drove
arthur mad and made him suffer knowing
that they had the power to stop bad
people from doing evil things before
they did them konchu already explained
that he is real justice judging people
for crimes they actually commit not ones
that they'll commit in the future arthur
stated that he knew what kanchi was
stating saying that he was real justice
so the two of them obviously had
arguments about that and that's why he's
trying to resurrect amit now so she can
judge people way before they commit
crimes and this is where the episode
leaves us what did you think of episode
three of moon night and let me know what
your favorite part of the episode was
don't forget to like the video and don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all things relating to the
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]